[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on analytical
validation for qpcr by victoria coe
i'm bill hanleiker from thermo fisher
scientific and i will be moderating
today's event
before we begin i would like to
encourage you to engage with us you can
submit as many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation simply type in your
question in the q a box on the left hand
side of your presentation screen and
click submit
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
please welcome victoria
thank you for taking the time to learn
about analytical validation consulting
services for qpcr assays
on the agenda today we're going to
discuss first what is a validation
followed by different accrediting
organization guidelines and then finally
analytical validation consulting
services provided to you by thermo
fisher scientific
first let's talk a little bit about what
is a validation as you can see there are
many different definitions here on what
a validation is let's hear from the fda
first they state a validation means
establishing by objective evidence that
a process consistently produces a result
or a product needs this predetermined
specifications
on the cat molecular checklist it states
a validation of a laboratory test
requires identifying the purpose of a
test and establishing demonstrated
evidence that provides a high degree of
assurance that the test will perform
consistently as expected
and then in terms of iso they state a
validation is a process of confirming
objective evidence to confirm that the
requirements that define a specific
intended use or application has been
fulfilled
overall these definitions are going to
vary slightly but there's one theme in
mind
a validation needs objective evidence to
confirm that the test or method is going
to deliver reliable results for the
intended application
first let's talk a little bit about
different accrediting organizations and
what they mean we'll start with clea
first
clea is the clinical laboratory
improvement amendment it was established
by congress in 1988.
it is the centers for medicare and
medicaid services also known as cms
clia requires clinical laboratories to
be certified by cms prior to accepting
any human samples for diagnostic testing
then we have cap which is the college of
american pathologist it's a group board
of certified pathologists it serves as a
point of contact for advocacy
publication learning and laboratory
improvement as well as cap proficiency
testing and accreditation
then we have new york state department
of health
in the u.s individual states have
approval to test residents that live
within that state
they have clear and very defined
requirements for ngs and qpcr panels
they are recognized by the fda as a
third party review organization to
review five 10k submissions
let's line up each accrediting agency
and talk about their specific guidelines
from clia they're going to cover all the
high complexity laboratory experiments
that need to cover in a validation
first we have accuracy
precision analytical sensitivity
specificity reportable range and
interval
when it comes to cap all the previous
high complexity experiments i just
listed are relevant however they have a
couple more requirements such as quality
cut off and clinical validation
performance
when it comes to new york state all of
the previous experiments i discussed
still stand however they have more
specific requirements within each
experiment type that need to be met
first let's talk a little bit about cap
in terms of accuracy accuracy is
validated by comparing results to a
definitive or reference method or an
established comparative method so for
qualitative tests
we need to look at the correlation to a
comparative test where on quantitative
tests we're looking for the closeness to
the true result
accuracy can be assessed by using
well-characterized samples in an
appropriate biological matrix or by
comparison to another valid test method
such as a specimen exchange
in terms of precision and
reproducibility it must show that the
test will return the same result
regardless as minor variations in
testing conditions that cause random
error such as different technologists
instruments reagents and even days
it's important to have enough repetition
of samples throughout the reportable
range to establish this
in terms of reportable range each
validation study must include sufficient
numbers of samples to confirm or
establish the test reportable range it's
important to encompass the full range of
reported values in terms of
pharmacogenetic studies
you need to make sure you cover all the
potential reportable outcomes such as
homozygous wild type heterozygous or
homozygous variant for all assays on
your panel
in terms of analytical sensitivity
or lower limit of detection it refers to
the ability of a test to confidently or
consistently detect variants in a
background of assay relevant biological
matrix which means that you need to find
your intended sample type such as urine
or swab media and you need to spike your
control material into your intended
sample type to take through your
extraction it's also important to
include
multiple biological replicates as well
as technical replicates throughout the
qpcr process
in terms of analytical specificity and
interfering substances it refers to the
ability of a test or procedure to
correctly identify or quantify an entity
in the presence of interfering or
cross-reactive substances that might be
expected to be present
running sufficient numbers of samples of
your intended sample type is going to
help here in this experiment
you want to run samples to examine
potential cross-reactivity and
near-neighbor interaction to establish
that inclusivity and exclusivity
when it comes to multiple instruments
it's important even if they are
identical that there must be records
showing of the exact serial number that
each instrument was separately validated
for reference interval it refers to the
range of results expected in the normal
healing population
for the qualitative cutoff this is for
qualitative tests that use a cutoff
value to distinguish a positive from a
negative sample
the cutoff value is established
initially using sufficient numbers of
samples
it is defined during the validation and
then translated in your standard
operating procedures
as a recap of all of the accrediting
organizations we discussed today
it is a stepwise approval based on the
stringency of guidelines so clea is at
the bottom
and then comes college of american
pathologist followed by new york state
being one of the most stringent
let's recap on what an analytical
validation is
the use of analytical technique process
and procedure to develop and produce
results in documentation form as
tangible evidence assuring that all
parts within the scope of a workflow are
suitable for their intended use
how frequently should you be performing
a validation well
anytime adding a new test to your menu
or adding a major change within your
workflow
changing potential sample types from say
urine tissues or swab
to even adding a new assay to your panel
in this next slide we have a timeline on
how long it takes inexperienced
consultants or diy customers to execute
a validation we average between 6 to 12
months for this
for month one we dedicate to project
planning where a laboratory is deciding
on their assay content followed by the
instrumentation and workflow used
then the laboratory initiates that po
process
and month two is the instrument
qualification and training
month three is pre-validation planning
where you're going to be drafting your
preliminary validation plans and
protocol
determining your samples your acceptance
criteria and bounds
followed by designing and ordering your
controls
in month 4 hopefully you are finalizing
your validation plan and starting
execution
followed by data collection
month 5 is dedicated solely to data
analysis
in month 6
hopefully you have finally completed
your validation report and you begin
clinical validation planning and testing
then comes post av where you submit your
documentation to your accrediting
organization and start working on the
reporting aspect
down below we have potential revenue
costs first you have your overall
investment around 200 000 for your
instrumentation and your workflow
then you need to consider the cost for
your control material which could cost
potentially around twenty thousand
dollars
followed by confirmatory testing which
could cost the laboratory thirty
thousand dollars and then finally be
outsourcing the data analysis piece
around twenty one thousand dollars
on average we help labs complete their
validation process up to seventy five
percent faster on their own
let's talk about common struggles with
the validation first the project
management piece
managing your day-to-day
responsibilities while developing a
validation is going to take a lot of
time and energy
next the control material piece just
sourcing and identifying the appropriate
controls for your panel takes a lot of
time
you may need to resort to designing
synthetic plasma control materials
then once you have the controls in your
hands you have to know how to prepare
them make dilutions and how to test them
in your workflow
followed by the data analysis piece you
have a large number of runs and it could
be almost 30 different run files that
need to be analyzed so you need to know
how to analyze that data and how to
establish your criteria cut off
then last is the documentation piece
meeting requirements for sops and your
report templates sometimes the assay
manuals don't always go into such great
detail as you would like
next we have the value of the upfront
investment and what critical personnel
you need to have during your validation
a project manager is key to this to
making sure you have designed a
successful validation plan
a data analysis is necessary because you
need to make sure that somebody knows
how to analyze these complex data sets
then an application scientist
it's important that you have the right
lab staff in your laboratory in order to
execute such qpcr experiments
av consulting services from thermo
fisher include integrated project
management data analysis consultation
and application support
let's talk a little bit about what av
services look like from thermo fisher
scientific
our av consulting services provide
clinical testing laboratories with fast
and cost-effective consultation for the
validation of qpcr assays and panels
that follow industry quality standards
and regulatory guidelines
we help save you time money and headache
on the timepiece you want to be the
laboratory of choice for your clients so
launching your assays and panels quickly
is a must
when it comes to cost launching new
assays with limiting staffing resources
is going to pose a risk to your
laboratory's bottom line
for compliance your laboratory is going
to face constant pressure of meeting
compliance requirements
and changes in these requirements are
often vague and broad making them
difficult to navigate
why you should choose thermo fisher for
your av consulting services first we're
going to provide you transparency we're
going to give complete visibility into
the av process data analysis and
summarization to facilitate regulatory
requirements and enable success as you
move into production
then integrated support we're going to
provide you highly experienced
scientists as your av project manager as
well as field application scientists to
support your workflow on-site
we are the end-to-end project management
support for your solutions from sample
prep to data analysis throughout the
full av
then flexibility and acceleration
the assessment of needs and initial
consultation are included in each
engagement to confirm that each lab is
going to receive an optimal solution for
your unique lab setup
we provide adaptable project management
solutions based on your needs and your
regulatory guidelines
we're going to accelerate the av process
for you with data analysis and summary
documentation towards enablement to help
achieve your reimbursement sooner
we have completed hundreds of av
consulting engagements and we have a
direct line to our research and
development team in case you need
something specific
our av consulting services help you
implement new assays faster and more
efficiently let's take it to the graph
on the left hand side we have the three
to six month timeline delay if you were
to execute the av on your own whereas on
the right hand side is you having thermo
fisher execute the validation with you
you have potentially two hundred
thousand dollars in savings and that's
because we can get the work done for you
within 10 to 15 weeks from start to
finish
what happens when you purchase our av
consulting services at thermo fisher
first we're going to help you decide
your panel content
decide on the best instrumentation for
your intended workflow and then help you
initiate that po process
once the instruments are on site we're
going to provide a field service
engineer to come out and install and
qualify your instrumentation
then we're going to provide you a
three-day on-site training to learn
about the workflow and instrumentation
we're going to provide a project manager
that's going to help with workflow
optimization and data analysis
then finally the validation piece
regardless if you have cap or clear or
new york state we can accommodate all of
your needs within 10 to 15 weeks
let's talk a little bit about what we're
going to provide you and what you're
going to receive
first we're going to provide you an av
specialist dedicated to your project
we're going to provide dedicated on-site
field application support
we're going to provide workflow training
guidance and optimization
followed by technical review with
guidance around data analysis
you're going to receive a validation
plan template in the form of an excel
document giving you step-by-step
guidance and a word document
then we're going to provide protocol
templates
we're going to give you a control
package that's going to include a
variety of control types such as genomic
control material plasma control material
and whole organism
then we're going to provide data
analysis consultation
we're also going to provide final report
templates and summary documentation
we support a variety of qpcr solutions
with our project management av
consulting services such as
pharmacogenetic testing respiratory
tract microbiota kova testing toenail
fungus urinary tract microbiota vaginal
microbiota wound microbiota and even
antibiotic resistance
thermo fisher can help accelerate your
launch time help reduce your cost and
transparency and facilitate lab
compliance with templates and
documentation
thank you for considering thermo fisher
scientific as your av consultant
thank you victoria for sharing that
insight into the av journey with us
we have received a couple of questions
already so our our first question is can
you please explain your validation
strategy in terms of meeting regulatory
guidelines
what guidelines do you use to help
ensure the lab is successful in their
validation
absolutely great question
in terms of meeting regulatory
guidelines for every customer engagement
a validation project manager would
inquire as to what accrediting
organization the laboratory wants to
meet
depending on the specific organization
we would design and optimize our
validation plan templates to accommodate
more stringent requirements we rely on
our laboratory partners to connect with
their accrediting organization to ensure
their validation plan will meet their
needs
and victoria what controls do you use in
the validation in other words how do you
help ensure that these are relevant for
the validation
absolutely
we use a variety of different control
types to meet various experiments so
whenever possible we use genomic dna or
rna as well as a custom plasmid or gene
string sometimes it's challenging to
source genomic control material for all
assays
some targets are just not culturable
we also use whole organism controls to
take through the extraction process to
ensure the extraction method is
sufficient for those hard to lyse
organisms
thank you so much victoria as a reminder
to our audience questions that we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed via the email address
that you provided at the time of
registration
so thank you again to our speaker
victoria quayet and everyone who
participated in this presentation we
hope you enjoy the rest of the event and
please be sure to check back frequently
for new content and presentations added
throughout the year
you